This talk is about
graph thinking,
and the slides are online.
There's a URL shown here.
Actually, there's a lot of
background material,
a lot of links.
Let's, let's consider
a scenario.
There's a village somewhere in
the woods.
In our village,
there's someone named Pat who
runs the pub, local pub.
Pat has a couple of friends,
Hannah and Thomas.
Now Hana works the fields,
grows the grain.
Hana has a friend
named Aiden.
Thomas works poultry,
raises hens and
produces eggs.
And Thomas has a friend
named Brenda.
And then Aiden is the miller,
Hannah's friend.
Hannah sells grain to Aiden.
Aiden, in turn,
has a friend named Chris.
And Brenda, Thomas's friend,
works the brewery.
Brenda buys grain from Hannah
and she makes beer,
which she sells to Pat,
who runs the pub.
Brenda also has
a friend named Kim.
And then Chris,
Iden's friend,
buys eggs from Thomas and buys
flour from Iden's mill and
produces bread. Chris
works the bakery.
And of course, his
bread is sold to Pat,
who runs the pub.
And then there's Kim,
Brenda's friend.
Kim works the recycler,
and Kim buys
organic waste from
Thomas and from
Brenda and Chris
and then mix
fertilizer to sell
back to Han.
So we had a graph that we
described there.
Now if we're gonna
put this into
a normalized form
for a relational
database, you see the schema
here on the left.
You would see maybe six tables
if you had a fully
normalized form.
And the thing is,
the information about
the relationships
in that village are completely
dismantled and destroyed and
atomized here by
having a relational
view. How can you look at this
and tell what those
relationships are?
On the other hand,
if you've got a graph,
you're presented with exactly
that context:
the relationships
of who knows who
in this village,
who produces what,
who sells to whom,
and just the general flow of
commerce that's
going on around
inside of this little Black
Forest medieval village.
Now the thing is that graphs
bring a kind of network view.
They bring the data closer to
people who can
make sense of it.
This is acknowledging
the the complexity
of the context.
This is about
identifying emergent
patterns. This is about being
able to make
informed decisions
based on the relationships
that exist.
That is the essence
of graph thinking.
Really it boils
down to thinking
in patterns. So
let's get a couple
of examples here.
Hannah's relatively
new in the village.
She'd like to expand
her business.
She's noticed that one
of her customers,
Brenda, happens to
buy a lot of grain.
Now who are
the other villagers
who are similar to Brenda?
Perhaps she could upsell.
Well, doing a little
bit of work
with the graph here,
you can see there's another
person named Chris who also
sells product to Pat,
also sells waste to Canon.
You know, maybe Chris's bakery
would be a direct
customer of Hana.
I don't know. Selling grain
directly to a bakery.
Maybe they could
sprout or make
malt or something like that.
Hannah is also interested in
sponsoring a co
marketing campaign
here in her medieval village.
And so she'd like
to try to help
drive the demand
for more grain.
So we can do some
analysis here.
Who are the customers
of Hannah's
grain customers?
And so for this,
we do some graph reversals.
We're looking a couple
of hops out.
We noticed that Chris, Pat,
and Kim are each a minimum of
two hops away.
And it turns out
we heard about
Kim a couple of times here.
And just to make it
more interesting,
a tech billionaire uses time
travel to relocate
back to this
medieval village in
the Black Forest.
Which businesses are the most
influential as
potential acquisition
targets? Well, it turns out if
you do some graph algorithms
based on this
data right here,
there's a family
called centrality.
There There's
a variant of this
called between the centrality
and it's really looking and
seeing which nodes are between
all the other nodes.
If you calculate that out,
you find that in fact Hana has
the highest ranking there for
between and centrality.
Chris has the second highest
ranking there. So, you know,
these are the businesses that
probably would be
your acquisition
targets for Musk
or, you know,
whomever. And it's interesting
to me that when I first showed
this graph to someone who has
absolutely no background on
graph algorithms,
my my friend,
she was able to
immediately look
at the graph, look at
the relationships,
and say, Hana's really hanging
out there. I mean,
the person making the grain is
raking in the money.
And indeed, that's what graph
algorithms show.
This is about
the complexity of
relationships.
Now there's a lot
of background when we study
complexity of relationships.
I wanna cover these
in a couple of ways.
If you go back to
nineteen ninety nine,
Dave Snowden was
a consultant at IBM,
and he developed a framework
called Kinev,
which tries to
assess a kind of
context in which
business leaders
are confronting problems and
need to be able
to apply decision
making. You may
have heard this
referenced. It it was where,
sort of the origin of
unknown unknowns,
which of course was referenced
after nine eleven.
But, in the Cynefin
framework,
you proceed from, say,
simple context where there are
established facts.
You just need to go in and
categorize the needs and apply
the best practices,
the rules.
Or you can progress in more
complicated kinds
of situations
where some kind of
expertise is needed,
some kind of analysis.
So analysts go in,
they assess the facts,
they provide their analysis,
and then leaders can respond
based off that
analysis, sort of,
you know, warehouses
and business
intelligence. But then you can
get into more complex business
environments where you really
must probe the situation.
There's no clear answer.
And the way through
it is to be
able to sense
emergent patterns
and make informed decisions
based off of
understanding those
patterns. And that
is the complex
side of business
decision making.
And increasingly
in our world,
we're seeing more
and more kinds
of complex challenges,
whether we're talking about
tangled supply
chains or pandemics
or on and on, climate
change, etcetera.
The world of
business has become
increasingly complex as we've
globalized, and
these are the kind
of things here that
must be applied.
This type of
confronting complexity
as opposed to
sweeping it under
the rug and just
trying to apply
best practices.
Now there's
a corollary also if
you look at pedagogy,
if you look at
learning theory.
Susan Ambrose,
has a book at
a two thousand ten
called How Learning Works,
and part of this
describes sort
of the journey from
being a novice,
a complete beginner
in a particular
subject, advancing
into someone
who's more advanced,
becoming more become competent
practitioner, and
then eventually
becoming an expert.
And what we find as
we're teaching,
as as people are
learning about
a new subject, when
they're novices,
they start out with memorizing
some facts, mostly
disconnected facts.
As people become
more advanced,
they gain more understanding.
They start to string
together the facts.
You get this kind of
linear thinking.
Amongst competent
practitioners though,
we see really what what could
be called decision
trees cognitive
structures that are much more
tree like in terms
of decision making.
But when people move into
expertise in a field,
what we see are essentially
learning how to
break the rules,
not just following
those decision
trees blindly,
but understanding
where they apply
and where they
they don't necessarily apply.
And that creates
cognitive structures,
which are graphs.
We should learn
something about
this that essentially
when we're
talking about
working in a complex
context, when we're talking
about learning
perceived emergent
patterns in a in a complex
challenging
situation and being
able to gain expertise on how
to behave in that
kind of environment,
we need to go move toward more
graph like cognitive
structures.
And this should be definitely
a clue for the way
forward with AI.
Relational data management and
reporting, that all arose from
simple business contexts.
And that led to
things like data
warehouses and data lakes,
practices like business
intelligence.
But the the complexities,
the uncertainties
of the twenty
first century,
this really forces
more where leaders
must increasingly
rely on sense making
by leveraging
the use of graph patterns.
Now in contrast,
there is something called
ambiguity aversion.
If you look this up,
it's it comes from cognitive
psychology but also behavioral
economics. And it
has to do with
how when faced
with uncertainty,
many people will do exactly
the wrong thing.
They'll make exactly
the wrong choice.
This is highly
important for AI
applications in
terms of helping
organizations and leaders be
able to augment their decision
making processes to
understand that,
in fact, some people just try
to sweep it under the rug.
But really, we
must be embracing
the complexity,
working with
emergent patterns,
working with graph thinking.
I'd like to acknowledge a good
friend colleague,
Juergen Buehler from,
BSF in Germany.
Juergen and I put
together this
scenario of
the village to explore
graph thinking and help to
illustrate this concept.
We have an article also that
goes in a bit more detail that
that's on Medium.
So talking about graphs.
You know,
the the thing is that
in business graphs,
connected data is everywhere.
Now when you talk
with people,
when you teach people about
doing data science,
when you talk with
people about data,
they typically respond by
describing a table,
rows and columns,
rectangles, matrices,
spreadsheets,
reporting tables,
these kinds of things.
People are trained to think in
terms of square patterns when
they hear the word data.
And, okay, that works except
when when it's not the case.
Spreadsheets, SQL reporting,
all these rely on graphs.
Within every Excel
spreadsheet,
there's a dependency graph.
That's the key to
calculating it.
Within every SQL query,
there is a query plan which is
directed acyclic graph.
There are complex
ERDs for being
able to represent
the scheme and
resolve that. The fact is that
these kinds of computational
techniques rely on graphs.
And in fact the metadata and
the business rules
which go part
and parcel with these
internal graphs,
they get obscured by the kind
of tabular format.
It becomes difficult
to troubleshoot
and test and reuse an audit.
It creates technical debt.
And if you don't believe me,
understand that ninety five
percent of the global
two thousand
companies in the world,
when they do their
final tax reporting,
the final stages
of ninety five
percent of the firms
is done in
spreadsheets. And
those spreadsheets
are not consistent from one
quarter to the next.
That is tech debt,
and it's a problem.
Gartner had been somewhat iffy
with regards to
graph technologies.
However, in early
twenty twenty
one in February,
Gartner did an about a face.
They're saying that,
graph technologies
will bump up
to eighty percent
of data analytics,
up from ten percent usage in
twenty twenty one.
Those are very rapid change.
And what they're
pointing toward
is this. By exposing metadata
and business rules,
the very thing
that gets obscured
by spreadsheets and relational
databases, which
leads to tech debt,
This is what
graphs surface and
allow domain
experts to be able
to manipulate. And so we're
seeing a lot of
rise of of graph
technologies,
this kind of usage
throughout industry.
It's appalling to
me when I talk
to people about graphs,
they immediately
say, oh, well,
that's that's just for Google
or Facebook, which is which is
utterly ridiculous.
When you look at it
in the industrial
applications, I I
know use cases,
for instance, in manufacturing
where one single
instance within
a manufacturing firm of their
graph applications,
one use case alone is larger
than the entirety of Google's
knowledge graph.
And this particular
company has
dozens and dozens of different
use cases. So I I I think that
this is a conceit to say that
the the Silicon Valley tech
firms have a lead in graph.
In fact, they're laggards.
The real problem with graphs,
this is happening
out in finance,
happening in pharma,
in manufacturing,
and a lot of areas of
regular industry,
not tech companies.
The common themes that we see
have to do with
data integration
across business silos,
having to do essentially
motif mining,
understanding data objects as
shapes or topologies,
geometries,
grappling with complexity and
uncertainty, working on
disambiguation
problems, working on,
you know, eliminating
cycles and data,
and also being able to drill
down the details,
which are which are critical,
more important than
just receiving
a bunch of aggregate accounts
that you would
typically get out
of a lot of BI tools.
You know, I'll point
out a few here.
Fudome, with Albert
Lezlo, Barbasi,
really, brilliant
work is they've
invented the term of
network medicine.
And there's a nature article
that describes what
they're doing.
If you haven't
seen this so far,
it's one of
the most sophisticated
uses of CRAP technologies and
probably some of
the most major
impact of what we'll see in
terms of of human outcomes.
Also, you know,
I'll point to drug discovery
from companies
like Novartis and
AstraZeneca, and we can talk
about Roche and many others.
I'm pointing here
especially to,
Stephen Reilings talks out of
Novartis using graphs for,
drug discovery,
Connor Hill at AstraZeneca,
in manufacturing.
I mentioned about
my colleague,
Jurgen Buehler at BASF, also,
Stefan Lempater and Thomas
Hjubauer at Siemens.
You know, definitely
in the tech firms,
you do see things
like Amazon's
product graph, and definitely
Luna Dom is doing some amazing
work there. Mark Grover was
formerly product
manager of data
at Lyft. He's done
some amazing work,
talking about their use cases
for metadata management
using graphs.
Refinitiv and
Bloomberg and others,
of course, in in
the tech space,
but, you know, Tom Baker and
others talking about that with
fintech data. And,
and certainly,
if you get a chance,
check out some of
the talks from
Charles Hay, Sheng Ma Hay at,
Ant Financial on
what they're doing.
And and if I were trying to to
sort of paraphrase a lot of
these industry presentations
about levering craft
technologies,
one of the models
that I use to
try to understand these these
case studies is
essentially this
triangle of know
your business,
know your customer,
and know your data.
So this is a a bit of rounding
the edges, but it's it's sort
of a a middle model for me to
try to understand
how are these
use cases related
to each other.
Okay. Let me shift
gears a bit.
Let me talk a little bit about
the graph theory because I I
think it's very important for
understanding how
do we leverage
what's happening in hardware.
I'll just say that.
So, we've had really good math
to handle graphs
for a long time.
And a typical kind of thing is
it's inside of algebraic
graph theory.
The idea is you have a complex
graph and you can
take parts of
it and push it into a vector.
You can vectorize it.
And and we do this when we're
training neural
networks a lot.
Alternatively,
you could take,
and represent the edges and
relationships in a graph by
using something,
a matrix representation.
So non negative matrix
factorization,
using things like
an adjacency matrix.
Or you can get a little bit
complex and use
something called
a tensor, which is essentially
like a three an n
dimensional matrix,
if you will. So
there's ways to
go between what
we call algebraic
objects, vectors,
matrices, tensors,
and graphs. You can transform
back and forth.
And for a long time,
the trick was to
use the matrix
approach. There's something
called non negative matrix
factorization, which
says, for instance,
we'll run page rank.
We'll take a graph.
We'll make a big
matrix out of it.
We'll apply a lot of linear
algebra and do
a lot of transforms
and compute up the results,
the rankings that we need.
And there's some
really fascinating
work on this. I
definitely point
you toward Tim Davis
at Texas a and m.
He runs the, Sparse
Matrix Museum.
You see pictured there,
also David Glack at
Purdue and others.
You know, some
of these folks,
Tim Davis, of course,
have been working
on graphBLAST.
Really fascinating
work in terms
of factorization,
but that's kind of what we've
seen in the past.
There's been a lot of that.
Sometimes you can't just get
away with this trick of taking
a complex graph and a lot of
symbolic relationships
and take
that information and making it
all numeric and then
number crunching.
Sometimes you
have to work with
symbolic. So certainly when
you're working on
graph visualizations,
when you're calculating deep
learning models,
training them,
when you're
recalculating graph
algorithms, you need to take
your graph and
put in some sort
of numeric
representation usually
to be efficient.
But when you're working with
natural language,
when you're understanding
regulatory compliance audits,
when you have
human loop, like,
some type of active
learning situations,
when you're trying
to represent
rules from domain expertise or
explainable AI,
these are cases where you need
to work more in the symbolic
representation. So,
what I recommend is this thing
with all apologies
to Daniel Kahneman,
what I call thinking
sparse and dense.
And this is the idea that when
you're in a data workflow
describing a pipeline and all
the transformations
across the data
workflow, there
are stages that
are more sparse
and stages that
are more dense.
Typically, when you're doing
your data preparation,
it's usually more sparse.
You pull things together and
oftentimes these
are relatively
bandwidth limited.
But then when you go
and train a model,
for instance,
it's probably more
compute limited.
And that's not always the case
when you're doing
a deep learning model.
You know, parts of
a deep learning
model, of course,
the convolution layers,
those will be
compute limited.
A lot of vector
processing there.
But when you have to calculate
a loss function in
deep learning,
this is bandwidth limited.
So thinking sparse and dense
across a problem, you know,
typically once
you've calculated
and trained your model,
then you have to apply it with
real world data.
So you sort of
shift from sparse
to dense back to sparse.
We go through this in
a lot more detail.
Dean Wampler and I
did a a report,
working with the open source
machine learning,
technology leads at NVIDIA,
earlier this year,
and it's a free
download if you
wanna check. It's
called hardware
greater than software,
greater than process.
And at the core
of this is this
mathematical idea that we can
go from a relatively complex
graph and then project it into
some other sort of space,
reshape it as a matrix,
reshape it as a tensor,
do our calculation,
transform it back,
and then populate the answers
that that we've gained
to the calculation
back into the graph.
So a lot of transforms
and inverse
transforms. And this is really
crucial for being
able to leverage
contemporary hardware.
And there's a whole bunch of
evolution going
on right now in
the hardware side
for accelerators,
for GPUs and FPGAs
and others,
etcetera. What this points to
is a general kind of narrative
in data science
about, you know,
starting with
unstructured data
and progressing
to more and more
structure and then leveraging
that structure.
And that is
about dimensionality
and how to really
manage dimensionality.
It's a really
essential component
of this trade up
between numeric
and symbolic representation
being able to shift back and
forth to those transforms.
So it's it's a lot
of how we're
projecting this
notion of graph
data science,
how to apply
graph technologies
in a very formal
way at different
points in a workflow
and how to
really manage and get the best
leverage out of it.
There's a GitHub
repo and a community
of developers around it.
Really, we we wanna
tackle a few things,
but, you know,
some of the main
parts about this
were that there's
a lot of great tools,
and they don't
necessarily play
well with each other.
There's a lot of
camps that are
working graph technologies,
different parts,
but they weren't
really talking
with each other.
And we wanted something that
would would work well in open
source with, you know,
a typical data science,
py data type
technology stack.
But at the same time,
still be very suitable for for
parallelization
with things like
Dask and Ray and RAPIDS and
Spark and that.
So we've been working on a lot
of integration.
We pull together
a lot of packages
into this kind of
abstraction layer.
And I I want to show a few of
these here. You know,
one is just when
you're building
the graph, if you want to work
with w three c
standards, RDF,
composing, graphs
out of triples,
basically, being
able to use a number
of different controlled
vocabularies.
So we support this and make it
a lot simpler than
the low level
tools like you would see in
already ebblib.
So with KGLab, you can define
your namespaces,
instantiate a graph,
and then just start adding
different nodes to it,
leveraging those namespaces.
If you're familiar
with w three c,
there's, like,
a dozen different
standards for how
to serialize.
And, of course,
we pick up support for those
along with making
use of things
like Pathlib and
FS spec codecs
and all that. Of course,
this has gone into
RDF lib six,
but we definitely
have support there.
You know, along with this,
a bunch of other
formats too if
you wanna work
with dot or or,
d max or in, you know,
some of these as
well as CSVs.
But the interesting thing that
we found is that Apache Arrow
and Apache Parquet are orders
of magnitude more efficient,
actually more than two orders
of magnitude more
efficient than,
say, using something like CSVs
or or some of
the forms of, like,
w three c standards
for serialization.
So, we highly recommend
using these,
and, and it really fits with
large distributed
graphs, by the way.
There's a number of excellent
tools in
the visualization space.
These don't necessarily blend
all that well with,
say, RDF lib.
So we built out
paths to be able
to do the transforms
back and forth.
Here, I'm showing how
to do a transform
for something called pyvis.
We have integrations
with Cairo
and Matplotlib, of course,
but also with our
forensic Graphistry,
which I highly recommend.
It's a GPU accelerated.
As far as querying, you know,
you can do sparkle queries,
but then you get back a named
tuple iterator or
a pandas data frame.
Again, something that's just
much easier to use
with the PyData
tech stack.
Shackle is, I think,
one of the one of my favorite
more recent
additions to w three
c stack and
certainly being able
to do shape constraints for
validation and prescription.
Really a lot of
great use cases
like unit tests.
Of course, there's
a there's a wide
range of different types of
graph algorithms,
but we provided pathways for
integration of
network x, iGraph,
and, of course, cuGraph for,
out of RAPIDS for GPU use.
And and we've been looking at
graph tools as
well to integrate
that further. There's been so
much going on in this field of
graph neural
networks and PyTorch
geometric etcetera.
And so we we do
support pathways
for integration with PyTorch
geometric and
there's also some
inference that's
been integrated
in terms of using statistical
relational learning that is to
say probabilistic graphs.
You can provide rules that are
probabilistic predicates and
then run probabilistic soft
logic on them, for instance.
And I find this is really,
really useful
because it's a way
of representing
uncertainty per node,
per edge, but
also for parts of
the graph overall.
And, of course,
there's a lot of
other types of
inference when we
talk about graphs.
We could be doing closures in
OWL or RDFS. We could be doing
transitive and SCAs.
Of course, deep learning graph
neural networks is
a form of inference.
There's also, you know,
types of inference that can be
drawn from graph algorithm use
such as clustering.
There's creative ways to do
inference with shackle.
What I want to point out here
is that not all of these are
quite the same.
In fact, you can plot them.
Some are better in terms of
formalism and more
analytic solutions.
Others are better at working
with messy noisy data and
represent and being able to
represent uncertainty.
The point that
we wanna make is
mix and match. For
a given use case.
Find out how can
you blend these
together. We see
how these types
of operations fit
in at each point.
Thank you very much.
If you wanna get
a hold of me,
here are some links.
Look forward to talking to you
on Twitter and
throughout the rest
of the conference